in the Brussels sunshine the woman
sitting on the steps breathing a book is
about to be cautioned she's out in
public without a good reason
and that is now against the law she's
very likely to get fined
we're out with the corona virus patrol
unit enforcing Belgium's new rules you
can be out for exercise or perhaps to go
shopping but sitting around will get you
were warning the fire getting bigger and
the Legler lose or people know the rules
they've had a week to understand that we
are much more strict and quick to hand
out fines don't respect the rules we've
been asked to obscure the faces of these
officers they are the front line of a
lockdown that's been in place for a week
we can't find people for no reasons we
find people because the government tells
us that we have to find them we talk to
people because the government tells us
that we have to talk to them we are the
government is our boss so we listen to
our government over at MIDI Station the
Eurostar train from London is about to
arrive Belgium has closed its borders to
most foreign visitors there will be more
being suggested of a particular the pier
we are living in strange times since the
appearance of this virus and this will
obviously have implications and our
travelers as well as for the police who
have had to adapt in light of this
emergency adapted situation to cross
around him preparations are made the
train is approaching the Cure than there
is for people who are not residents and
they are being asked exactly what
they're doing in this country if the
tourists for instance they won't be
allowed entry there are about 55
passengers on this train and they've
been greeted by 16 armed police officers
the checks here are thorough
documents and evidence are expected each
person has spoken to him
among the arrivals a familiar face
Britain's ambassador to the European
Union himself questioned if that's what
the authorities think we should be doing
I haven't heard anybody complain you
know and I think everywhere we need to
follow what respective authorities say
back in the middle of the city the
coronavirus team now petroleum as a car
this is the reality of lockdown in
Western Europe Belgium hasn't become a
police state but it is different it's
not life as we knew it
Adam Parsons Sky News Brussels